this one hits and this one hits so hard  one of the great things that people  continue to misunderstand is being kind  to other people leads to you being happy  you know some of the greatest things in  the world feel  and this happens to be one of the this  study has gotten a little press here in  the last couple of weeks and it's just  so clear to me that if you could just  start by doing little micro nice things  to others you will be flabbergasted of  what that does for your soul what what  it does for you inside it's a nice  gesture buying somebody a coffee in your  office  complimenting somebody on something out  of 11  random hello and love to someone you  haven't talked to in a while please  start practicing kindness and be stunned  if it does